we act and we create theatre as a
reflection of humanity reflecting what's
going on around us in society so it's
really important to be connected to that
and connected to not only the people in
the arts and in our College of Fine Arts
but within the whole university classes
here are very small I mean I have nine
people in my class now and we've take
every single class together and you
become a literal family you're around
all these people that are unbelievably
talented every day and the conservatory
training here really pulls out and it
forces you to go beyond where you
thought your limits were every day every
class we want our students not only to
be going into other projects but
creating their own I mean that's what if
that's what innovation is going to be
about they I hope are going to be
changing our profession and they're
going to be doing that through the tools
that we gave them and breaking and
breaking the rules after being through
the four years of the program you can
look back and realize that it it was the
best decision I ever made to come here
because I am so prepared for the next
level of our business you have to do
this because you love to do it and you
have to do it for the right reasons and
that's what we build into our program so
that our students have the strength to
survive